[Music]
on this saturday night covid cases ramp
up as some canadian regions
shut down tough new measures take effect
to curb the spread
political risk
donald trump speaks to hundreds at the
white house just over a week after
testing positive
a frightening spread of a different kind
it's seen as a kind of threat to the
nation
poland's anti-lgbtq ideology grows
and how fear a lot of people were
worried drove one of the most
popular pandemic pastimes
[Music]
global national with robin gill
reporting tonight
colleen christie good evening thanks for
joining us as canadians alter their
traditions this thanksgiving weekend
because of covet 19
cases continue to soar in many parts of
canada
in quebec police checkpoints have been
put up to help curb the spread while in
parts of ontario
new restrictions are now in place as the
province's death toll surpasses 3
000. jeff semple is following the
developments tonight in toronto
jeff colleen people here in toronto
in ottawa and next door in peel region
woke up this morning to a dreaded
deja vu it is frustrating global news
first interviewed this toronto
restaurant owner last summer during the
first wave in lockdown
a second closure will be perhaps even
worse for us
fast forward a few months and his fears
have been realized
we risk worst case scenarios ontario now
shuttering all indoor
dining movie theaters casinos and gyms
in toronto peel and ottawa
this gym invested thousands of dollars
in air purifiers and plexiglas
and just reopened its doors after being
forced to close for three months
that's almost half a year of our income
that's going to be gone
they like many others are now shifting
their service outdoors
keeping a nervous eye on the weather
last time that we spoke
we were heading into the summer so we
knew that we were going to be busy in
the patio
now we can only trade in the patio but
we know that we're going to the
cold months the ontario government now
facing a chorus of criticism for not
taking steps sooner to slow the spread
we waited too long during the slow part
of exponential growth
now we're in the rapid part of
exponential growth so we have to do
things harder
canada's largest provinces ontario and
quebec have the highest number of cases
but the provincial picture per capita
tells a different story with quebec
manitoba
and alberta topping the list i think
within the city of edmonton
we're starting to see the beginning of a
second wave after quebec and ontario
reimposed restrictions experts worry
alberta could be next
toronto has around 58 active cases per
hundred thousand people
edmonton has a hundred and eight the
alberta government is relying on
voluntary restrictions to limit
gatherings in large groups
and alberta's premier sounds a lot like
doug ford did a couple of weeks ago
we're not going to enforce our way out
of this there was action taken with
voluntary recommendations and guidelines
if that is not effective over the next
two weeks we may have no choice
but to bring in more formal closures or
restrictions
in canada's hardest hit province
meanwhile police are enforcing the
lockdown with checkpoints
ensuring quebecers don't travel too far
from home for thanksgiving
and ontario is also following quebec's
lead when it comes to the length of this
latest
lockdown these restrictions will remain
in place for at least the next
28 days colleen
jeff thank you three of four atlantic
provinces are reporting new cases today
and new brunswick set another single day
record
the province reported 20 new cases most
of them
in the province's two orange zones 12
were in moncton where there's an ongoing
outbreak at a long-term care home
seven others are in the campbellton area
in the northern part of the
province neighboring nova scotia has
three new cases but the provincial
government says the infections aren't
related to the outbreaks in new
brunswick
prince edward island didn't report any
new cases but officials there have
warned islanders against
traveling to new brunswick's orange
zones over this weekend
and three people in newfoundland and
labrador have tested positive
but those numbers are a small fraction
of the more than 7.7 million
infections in the u.s since the pandemic
began
despite that president donald trump who
has kovit 19
addressed another large crowd on the
white house lawn today
as jennifer johnson reports he's
continuing to downplay his own illness
and the risk of the virus
desperate to recharge his campaign u.s
president donald trump hosted hundreds
of supporters at the white house
just days after being hospitalized for
covet 19.
some of the attendees were invited by
the blexit group a campaign urging black
americans to leave the democratic party
the president spoke from an upstairs
balcony the spot where he took off his
mask
after returning from walter reed
national military medical center monday
night
our nation's going to defeat this
terrible china virus as we call it
and we're producing powerful therapies
and drugs and
we're healing the sick the outdoor
gathering with few physically distancing
took place exactly two weeks after the
supreme court nomination ceremony
for judge amy coney barrett several
people who attended that later tested
positive for kova 19
including the president and first lady
we had a super spreader
event in the white house and it was in a
situation
where people were crowded together and
were not wearing masks
the president pushed for saturday's
event while still skirting the question
of whether he is now tested negative for
the virus
but i've been retested and i know i'm at
either the bottom of the scale or free
it's really at a level now that's been
great
great to see it disappear the president
continues to downplay the threat of
cobit 19
as the u.s centers for disease control
and prevention reports new cases have
hit a two-month high
with 10 states reporting record
increases
on the campaign trail democratic
candidate joe biden continues to blast
the president
for what he calls reckless actions i
just read
that the cdc was going to require mass
on public transportation
40 000 people a day are coming down with
coronavirus
and they in the white house blocked it
what is the matter with this guy
the president's campaign says it was not
involved in planning this event and
several inside the white house were
reportedly against it
but the president is not backing down in
his battle to get reelected
a major rally is scheduled monday night
in florida campaign officials say
attendees will have their temperatures
checked
and encouraged to wear masks jennifer
johnson
global news washington today president
trump received a phone call from prime
minister justin trudeau who wished him
and the first lady well in their
recovery from covet 19.
the two leaders discussed ongoing
efforts to manage the pandemic
this week the prime minister warned
canada is at a tipping point
mercedes stephenson sat down with
canada's chief science advisor to get
her take on the pandemic mercedes joins
us now with what we can expect
on the west block this week mercedes
colleen i spoke with dr niemer for over
30 minutes to get to the bottom of some
of our most
pressing questions about covid19 on the
vaccine canada's chief science advisor
said
that it could be available as soon as
early 2021. that's just a few months
away
on her advice to the government dr
niemer says
that scientists are being heard by
politicians
we had a lot to talk about so here's a
sneak peek of what she had to say about
the second wave of covid19 that much of
the country
now finds itself in the grips of you
know the second wave is gonna
look what we are going to make it
look like meaning through our actions
and
and what we do because i think that we
have everything in hand
uh to make sure that the second wave is
actually
as smaller uh and shorter
than uh than the first wave it's a
matter of
following public health guidance covet
19 has made us rethink the way we do
well just about everything here in
canada justice minister and attorney
general david lametty joins us this week
as well to talk about
how the pandemic has impacted the courts
and whether serious charges like murder
could be dropped due to long delays in
going to trial caused by the pandemic
here's what he had to say the the
effects have been multiple
in terms of the way a court can hear
when it's an in-person session
if there's a jury trial how do you space
the jury how do you empanel the jury
in a safe way how do you make sure that
everybody who
walks into that court building from
participants in the in the process of
the parties to a case
to the lawyers to the judges to the
support staff
you have to make sure that the whole
thing is functioning in a safe
manner former interim leader of the
conservative party rana ambrose also
joins us on the west block this week
we'll talk to her about that sexual
assault training bill now on round three
of going through parliament
as well as the view from alberta when it
comes to federal government pandemic
spending
colleen thanks so much mercedes people
living along the louisiana coast are
assessing the damage from
delta it blew ashore as a category 2
storm last night before weakening as it
moved further inland
there weren't any deaths blamed on the
storm but it brought flooding to some
areas
ripped up trees and downed power lines
it knocked out electricity to about
25 percent of the state's power
customers the same area of louisiana
was already recovering from the impact
of the much more powerful hurricane
laura
which struck six weeks ago
it affects you physically mentally
psychologically and then
to turn around six weeks later and
experience it again is is pretty tough
delta was the tenth named storm to hit
the mainland u.s
this hurricane season that's a new
record hurricane season doesn't
officially
end until november 30th coming up a
dangerous and growing ideology poland's
anti-lgbtq stance
and fighting resumes in the disputed
nagorno-karabakh region following a
short-lived ceasefire
fighting appears to have resumed in the
disputed nagorno-karabakh
region just hours after armenia and
azerbaijan
agreed to a ceasefire the russian
brokered deal was scheduled to start
today but
both sides are already accusing each
other of breaking the truce
the moscow talks were the first
diplomatic contact between the two
countries since fighting began nearly
two weeks ago
nagorno-karabakh is internationally
recognized as part of azerbaijan
but it's governed by ethnic armenians
poland is also getting international
attention right now for all the wrong
reasons this year at least 100
communities have declared themselves
lgbt free zones dozens of countries
including canada have condemned the
action
now at least one canadian organization
that helps lgbt people escape
persecution and violence
is expecting people to flee poland mike
delay explains
with every wave of the rainbow flag
poland's lgbt community fans the flames
of those who hate them
groups of right-wing nationalists like
these just don't want to see it anymore
according to our faith according to our
traditions
and according to nature it's a nature to
be lgbt
it's an ideology that's spreading town
councils in over a third of the country
have passed resolutions declaring
themselves
anti-lgbt zones they're unenforceable
because it's not illegal to be gay
but lgbt activists are afraid of what
might happen next
lgbt people cannot count on polish
government because they
targeted us and show us to the people as
a public enemy
the european union has tried to put
pressure on the polish government to
step
in but polish president andre duda
doesn't appear to be listening
he wants to ban schools from teaching
anything about
lgbt issues and he compared the movement
to communism
an emotional trigger for many in poland
the basic
idea is that somehow lgbt people
represent a threat to
a kind of traditional values or
particular forms of the family
and in the way in which polish
nationalism presents itself these
days it's seen as a kind of threat to
the nation the idea of a threat is
what's fueled the growth of right-wing
nationalism in europe
extreme right-wing parties are either
active and growing
already winning seats in parliament or
running governments outright
gay rights in poland are considered
among the weakest in europe
while same-sex relationships are legal
there are no protections for hate crimes
or hate speech
and the rainbow railroad which helps
lgbt people escape persecution and
violence
is expecting a spike in requests to help
leave the country
that's when they usually come to us for
help when
essentially uh folks are criminalized
within
their towns and local communities and
cannot
rely on any sort of uh protection
from the state given the presence of the
remains of nazi concentration camps in
the country
many observers are surprised the polish
government is enabling those
who are so willing to persecute a
minority group
mike delay global news still ahead of
the technology making sea travel
safer cheaper and greener
you're watching global national
north korea's military might was on
display today during a rare pre-dawn
parade
it featured a previously unseen
intercontinental ballistic missile
experts say it would be one of the
largest in the world if it becomes
operational the parade was held to mark
the 75th anniversary of the country's
ruling party but north korea typically
uses events like this
to show off new weapons it's not just
socializing we're doing from a distance
these days
military and commercial drones have
revolutionized how we see
and navigate our planet in the next
decade
sea vessels without crews could do the
same for the worldwide shipping industry
potentially making it safer cheaper and
greener
redmond shannon visited one uk
manufacturer on the cutting edge of
sailor-free marine technology
the usv max lemur is back on dry land
during a recent three-week mission
surveying the atlantic seabed
the uncrewed surface vessel pushed new
boundaries of maritime technology
all controlled from this room back at
base in the east of england
over the course of the 22 days we
managed to survey over a thousand square
kilometers
the intention of the project itself was
to go out and prove how this vessel will
handle in
true ocean conditions for longer periods
of time so we're off there for 22 days
the mission was actually a plan b plan a
was to attempt a historic
unmanned transatlantic voyage from nova
scotia to england
until covert 19 made the logistics
impossible
the usb maximum will fit in a single
40-foot container
that single 40-foot container can be
shipped anywhere around the world for
for tens of thousands
versus a mobilization which can go up to
a million just to mobilize a vessel
the production and operating costs are
also a fraction of conventional
surveying vessels
uncrewed ships are about more than just
economics and efficiencies
the technology could have an impact on
the carbon footprint of the wider
shipping industry right now the industry
has a similar sized emissions impact to
aviation
as this technology develops freighters
won't need
bulky accommodation potentially making
them smaller
and lighter on top of that we start to
have crew when you
operate in the gulf of mexico and you've
got crew from all around the world you
need to fly them out there and each of
those flights
has its own carbon footprint surveying
company fugro has just ordered
two vessels to deploy its underwater
vehicles for
oil and gas pipeline inspections at the
moment there's no
no regulation in place for foreign
operations
the company is working with authorities
to set out new rules to govern the
future of
unmanned sea travel what we are facing
now actually is this this transformation
supported by all the all the
technologies that we have at hand
at a super high speed it's really it's a
big fun to work on this and to to work
on this
on this change but it's uh it's massive
it's it's
massive meanwhile another project named
the mayflower
aims to use artificial intelligence
systems for an uncrewed
transatlantic crossing next year redmond
shannon global news
tullsbury england no suitcase no
passport no problem
for passengers on board a qantas
airlines flight nowhere
150 people boarded a plane in sydney
only to return a few hours later
qantas sold a sightseeing tour over
australia's landmarks
to help boost the ayling airline each
seat was snapped up in about 10 minutes
with a first class ticket costing nearly
4
thousand dollars critics say the flight
isn't worth the environmental cost
up next what we're learning about the
modern version
of the victory garden
there's enthusiasm for you these little
guys are literally
jumping at the chance to be part of this
competition
it's the first ever canadian regional
dog
diving championship dogs are enticed to
run the length of a dock and leap as far
as possible into the water
they're judged on height and distance
it's very exhilarating and i know that
he's having a lot of fun and happiness
when he does it
sure looks like it competitors would
normally travel to florida for the
competition but
because of the pandemic nine regional
competitions are being held across the
continent
in search of the top dogs i think he
should win
well while you may have dug in for the
fall and winter some new
stats are in for a springtime pandemic
phenomenon the
rise in the popularity of gardening
particularly vegetable gardening
while it served as a great way to fill
time at home
as ross lord reports that's not why a
lot of people took it up
backyard gardens like this one in the
halifax area are popping up all over
canada
for many it's a way to finally indulge
their green thumbs
we've wanted to do gardening for quite a
while and we've always said it in the
years gone by but with kovid
we really thought this is the time an
online survey of one thousand canadians
by dalhousie university researchers
shows the trend is widespread we found
that
51 percent of our respondents grow at
least one fruit or vegetable at home
which is it surprised us the report says
17 percent of home gardeners started
this year
during the pandemic 67 percent of those
new gardeners
say the pandemic influenced their
decision and the report suggests
there's a fear factor more than half of
respondents expressing at least
some worry about food shortages during
covet 19.
i wasn't really scared food would no
longer be available but there's that
little bit of we should be trying to
grow some of our own food anyway
and that's to be more sustainable
there's such an explosion in home
gardening
the federal government now has a website
with safety instructions on canning food
when the pandemic first broke out in
march a lot of people were worried
especially greenhouses and garden
centers that
this would be a year where you know some
maybe would have gone out of business it
wouldn't be busy
but instead we saw gardeners so many new
gardeners a lot of people come back to
gardening
an upside to the pandemic that's
literally growing
ross lord global news windsor nova
scotia
that is global national for this
saturday i'm colleen christie
tonight's york canada is a horse's eye
view of the village of
innisfree in alberta we love showcasing
your part of canada email your photos to
viewers at globalnational.com
thanks for watching hope you'll join us
again tomorrow good night
[Music]